it's very interesting and it's extremely
varied we were talking about this
earlier today when you read these for
instance the Gospel of Thomas is older
than Luke or Matthew and it contains a
whole bunch of stories called infancy
stories stories of Christ as a child and
young man
they are the weirdest stories and what
is this word weird mean it means that
they have a strange vibration about them
and it is that strange vibration that
caused them to be excluded from the
canonical books for instance as an
example in the Gospel of Thomas there's
a story since you happen to ask well
anyway it's a story about Christ as a
young child in which several times he
just zaps people dead who get in his way
there's another story in the in the
Gospel according to Philip where Christ
he and the Apostles are going or moving
from one town to another and he becomes
hungry and he approaches a bush at the
side of the road and he says make thou
food nothing happens he says it again
make thou food nothing happens he says
it again and the final line of the
incident is and he destroyed it with
fire now
so we see there you see an alien Christ
a Christ that we can't relate to but
also you have to remind yourself how how
dulled our ear is to the Christ that we
do know for instance I'm sure if you're
into this at all and you're familiar
with the famous Pat the gospel passage
where he Institute's the Eucharist takee
and drink for this is my body and this
is my blood which is being shared unto
the conversion of many for the new and
never-ending covenant this hit like a
bombshell and it even says in the biblic
in the in the Gospels description of it
and many drew away from him at that time
I mean that was too much preaching that
you should eat the flesh and drink the
blood of the teacher just people said
you know we're checking out on this it's
gotten too weird now we've had 2000
years to smooth it all out and explain
what he really meant and how it's okay
and it's this wonderful beautiful
symbolic statement of the aphagia etc
etc but how about it when it was raw you
know and you were there at the table and
this rap went around it would be I think
quite peculiar
it's interesting that when the
Franciscans reached the mushroom cults
of central Mexico in the 16th century
and they said what do you call this
stuff and they said oh we call it tienen
a coddled
it means flesh of the Gods they were
appalled and immediately the Inquisition
went to work and everybody who would
admit to that was put to death because
it was such an appalling notion and yet
it was an exact to an exact formulation
of the Eucharistic mystery
the first thing I'm going to read is
just a small portion of the Gospel of
Thomas now this is the comes out of that
body of Gnostic literature that is most
closely related and comparative with
Christianity this is from the document I
mentioned which is older than Luke and
Matthew and is in a uncertain
relationship to the cue document from
Qumran the stories of Thomas the
Israelite the philosopher concerning the
works of the childhood of the Lord I
Thomas the Israelite tell unto you even
all the brethren that are of the
Gentiles to make none known unto you the
works of the childhood of our Lord Jesus
Christ and his mighty deeds even all
that he did when he was born in our land
wherever the beginning is this this
little child Jesus when he was 5 years
old was playing at the Ford of a brook
and he gathered together the water and
flowed there into pools and made them
straightway clean and commanded them by
his word alone and having made soft clay
he fashioned thereof 12 sparrows and it
was the Sabbath when he did these things
and there were also many other little
children playing with him and a certain
Jew when he saw what Jesus did playing
upon the Sabbath day departed
straightway and told his father Joseph
lo thy child is at the brook and he hath
taken clay in fashion 12 little birds
and have polluted the Sabbath day and
Joseph came to the place and saw and
cried out to him saying wherefore dost
thou do these things on the Sabbath
which it is not lawful to do but Jesus
clapped his hands together and cried out
to the sparrows and said to them go and
the sparrows took flight and went away
chirping and when the Jews saw it they
were amazed and departed and told their
chief man that which they had seen Jesus
do but the son of a mouse the scribe was
standing there with Joseph
and he took a branch of a willow and
dispersed the waters which Jesus had
gathered together and when Jesus saw
what was done he was wroth and said unto
Him o evil ungodly and foolish one what
hurt did the pools and the waters do
thee behold now also thou shalt be
withered like a tree and shall not
berlioz neither root nor fruit and
straightaway that lad withered up wholly
but Jesus departed and went unto
Joseph's house but the parents of him
that was withered took him up be wailing
his youth and brought him to Jesus and
accursed him for that thou hast such a
child which do with such deeds and it
goes on eventually he straightens the
Gong out but but not before he deserves
two more people dead so it's an example
of you see what the patristic fathers
did was they gather together all of this
literature and they have a set of ethics
that they wanted to canonize and so they
eliminated everything which did not fit
with that materials such as this this by
the way is the apocryphal New Testament
be Mr James edition which is
indispensable for this kind of screen
there is enough material to suggest that
Christ was someone's follower and that
what he was saying
had been said a generation earlier by
someone else of whom we have no trace
and you know this is hot hot stuff
because it just cannot be that way if
you're Orthodox and but anyway this this
was what dick felt about Pike whom he
knew very well and if the transfer
migration or transformation of timothy
archer is an excellent book to read to
see how modern church man have dealt
with this it's scandalous that the NAG
Hammadi library is not bit more
widely discussed because it represents
the strongest doctrinal challenge to
Christianity in its history there has
never been anything this explosive
because it casts such doubt on the
moments of the origins and such doubt
the on whether or not we have any
contact with the career of a Galilean
who was the son of a carpenter and so on
it just seems to explode the entire
foundation of Christian hermeneutics and
there's excitement in the schools of
theology they are totally aware of this
but it doesn't seem to have filtered
down to the lay level and perhaps it
never will it may be like the Grand
Inquisitor this thing coming out of the
ground is the most unwelcome thing that
could appear on the scene in modern
Christianity they are it fouls it up
hopelessly you realize when I refer to
the Grand Inquisitor I mean the scene in
The Brothers Karamazov the story of
Christ returning and to a city in which
the Inquisition is happening and his
dialogue with the Grand Inquisitor who
knows full well that its Christ but he's
talking to you and who explains to him
that he shouldn't have come they have
things well in hand it's only going to
make a problem
[Music]
you
[Music]